doesn't end this way you can't
is that what your magic [ __ ] fairy
visions say because it sure as hell
doesn't look like we're getting out of
here any
what no no no it's okay
something happens
who the hell are you
hey where are you taking us who the hell
are you people
all your questions will be answered when
we reach dr scurlock it's too late we're
not making it any doctor
stand down or your people will die
you'll [ __ ] die with them
i'm not threatening them [ __ ] i'm
trying to save them
the hell what exactly is in this
please please do not fear
my name is nathan scurlock xenobiologist
dr abraham zahidi can you explain to me
oh my what an unexpected honor i was a
follower of your father's work
at least um as long as possible
i haven't uh so much a claim to fame as
you can see
there is one breakthrough of mine that
served us rather well
just tell us how it works um yes yes of
course
my apologies the fungus wasn't always
like this
its dna was altered my formula merely
tells the fungus against itself
here all who are brave enough to reach
us are free to live in peace
my antidote must be injected daily none
of us dare stay far away from the camp
without it
with this small ceremony each month not
just in time for one
no alters i'm afraid i hope that
the rest of your convoy will attend this
evening we're not planning on staying
long
oh beyond here there's only death
until the truck is repaired we're stuck
here anyway
good thank you
look what i found in the forest
this was cuthbert's we've been here
before
well [ __ ] i thought things looked
familiar
but i thought it was skirlock's drugs
but unless you can pull a spare oil pump
from your ass
we're not going very far we left a truck
here before
that day the first storm hit maybe i can
find it find it that was 30 years ago
not for me
this isn't gonna take
watch where
maybe a costar mercer are here i should
ask around if i want to solve this
outrider's bunker mystery
only to get [ __ ] out of some ugly
hey do you remember my tunes i used to
play
like it was yesterday i can still
remember some of them
um please stop
yeah i'm totally serious
[Music]
um
outrider you wouldn't believe how much
i've learned from dr scurlock here
don't get distracted that's not what
we're here for but part of the reason
we're here in the first place is to find
a way out of the trenches for everyone
what if we brought the antidote back to
shira we'd also bring the summary
execution of everyone who makes the
antidote
they're deserters remember oh
yes i hadn't considered that
um
so
hey you got a plan what we're gonna do
about all these desserts
we're not doing anything with them
bailey are you kidding me
these people abandoned the eca they're
traitors
we're sticking with the mission you can
go back to corrigan empty-handed
or you can fall in line
alright this is dr scarlock i must
profess it it's been a delight to have
met yourself and your companions
we're grateful for the help doctor but i
have to ask
your antidote to the fungus why do you
keep it to yourselves out here
our people are trapped in the valley if
they knew that yes
if they knew think about it what's the
first thing they would do
they would be so afraid of the other
side getting it they'd be locked up
war is all they know how to think about
those narrow-minded tribal idiots
out here it's different we're all free
we don't live in fear of our neighbors
stood in our throats
men and women allies and enemies
here nature the elements are our only
enemy
sounds too good to be true well it's we
do what we can do
resources are scarce but you and your
companions may stay as long as you need
[Music]
so
the one who dragged your friends from
the underworld i will be handling your
induction
induction as i told skurlock we're just
passing through
scurlock has no say in who stays or
leaves i'm in command of the cast
security
sure but this camp wouldn't exist
without speaker locking his vaccine
wouldn't exist without my soldiers can i
do anything for you
it pleases me that you won't be here
long
so
back
so
so
so
yeah i found the truck what's it look
like
exactly as we left it you have something
in common
get that oil
okay i've got the pump from the truck
good
now hurry back this meathead kang hasn't
i died
screw till they push back then loosen a
little
hey you forget everything i taught you
taught me you think you taught me
anything old man
unbelievable
feisty she definitely got her temper
from you
looks like we're taking a break
i guess you've earned the right to hear
the full story
so uh a long time ago
before this shitty planet before we even
left earth
i was flying workers to the caravel
orbit station
the flames started to surround me and i
tried to find an exit
that's when i tripped and i saw this
damn pregnant woman lying under the
rubble
i was able to save both of us
well sri hold on you were there during
the caraval disaster
all the survivors of the caraval were
given the free ticket aboard the brand
new flores and
i met her again right here
in trench town her child was born
it was a girl and she named her chanda
then that little brand was only
six when she saw her mother killed right
in front of her
so you raised her go on
the truck isn't going to fix itself
so
you see my wife
did he tell you how my mother died i'm
sorry
no kid should have to see that even
better
i saw it twice the first time in a
vision
you know i tracked down jacob begged him
to come back
because he wasn't there in the vision
when she died i thought
if he was there maybe it wouldn't come
true
but jacob doesn't listen to anything i
say
outrider if i may as an altered you are
not allowed to join our ceremony
due to scientific complexity but rest
assured your presence in our humble camp
is appreciated
few make it out this far alive even less
mean to keep going what is it you're
looking for
friend
i'm not your friend you don't know
what's out there
there are things i could tell you things
i could warn you about
but you would not believe these things
and what makes you so sure
because the things i've seen even i do
not believe them
that was kurlock's little ceremony how
was it
it was weird a bunch of rambling
speeches about brotherhood we all pick
stones from a basket
hey there is music and free drugs so not
all bad where's zahidi
went off with scurlock talking some
science mumbo jumbo
well he'll be back no he won't
your friend picked the black stone
what are you talking about they're
taking him to the facility
get me out of here i'll lead you
zahidi where are you
zahidi do you copy
you know i wouldn't have recognized this
forest if you hadn't said
scurlock makes his antidote here very
few
know what goes on inside and
how do you i used to help him make it
until he took a friend of mine prisoner